you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game we
certainly need to turn the clocks back
for nearly 160 years ago Louis Paulson
competed against Paul Morphy in the
finals of the first American chess
congress this was a knockout format
tournament held in New York in 1857 this
event this American chess congress was a
predecessor to what we know today as the
US Chess Championship so let's see how
this game was played many moons ago
Louis Paulson opened with e4 Paul Morphy
replying e5 we have on board a Spanish
for Knights Bishop c5 both sides Castle
white goes with this little tactical
sequence capturing on e5 preparing to
meet Knight takes Knight with D for
winning the material back black instead
activates another piece Knight takes
Knight D takes bishop C form the best
move in this position is Knight G form
and this is a move that looks to take
advantage of the fact that white is
absent their number one King side
defender namely a white knight on f3
this adds a second strike to f2 and
enables potential pressure with Queen h4
against the white King side there is one
additional idea in mind and I will
illustrate that after h3 black can
actually take twice on f2 and end with a
fork of the King and Bishop b5 was
played in the game asking the bishop a
very important question which of these
two diagonals will you choose the more
aggressive looking Bishop b3 staying
opposite the King can be met with Bishop
g4 development with tempo and White has
to do awkward stuff like Queen e1 going
into a pin and maybe even there's a case
where the Queen could be lost
short story here is that on b5 white
needs to take up the more modest post
the better post on e2 only at this point
only after the bishop has been kicked
off of this diagonal does black regain
the pun with night take see why is this
so important why is it so important that
black first kicks the bishop off of this
diagonal prior to capturing on e4 well
suppose Knight takes e4 here you'll note
that black is without their number one
King side defender a black knight on f6
and this would allow a tactical sequence
capturing on f7 capturing on e4 and then
a fork against the rook and King white
is soon to be up the exchange neither of
those two Illustrated tactics towards
the enemy Kings are present with these
key defenders on f3 + f6 after b5 Bishop
e2 Knight take see light takes Knight
rook takes Knight Bishop f3 this is an
excellent post for the bishop and he's
getting there with a strike
rookie 6 defend c6 and now c3 preparing
d4 allowing the bishop to come out and
looks to shut down black's dark square
bishop at the same time c3 provides a
gap in the white position on d3 and this
is something black makes use of right
away with Queen d3 is this something
that white didn't see I don't believe
that that is the case I believe white
had a deeper idea in mind in reply to
black occupying d3 with their queen what
is that what is that idea exactly well
it's B for Bishop b6 a form now what
does this accomplish exactly these I
this a queen side expansion B for a 4
well after a4 is in it can be said that
black can no longer maintain both a
black pawn on b5 and the Queen undies
why is this the case well the c-pawn
note is not really there as a defender
of b5 it's in a pin and how else are you
to maintain upon here playing a6 well
actually there are multiple pins towards
this rook 8xb and you're losing your
rook one other point is if you get off
of this diagonal well there is an
additional point behind a4 and that is
a5 in your bishops trapped short story
here is that on a4 black has to give up
the beep on recapturing with the Queen
just to show well not with that dummy
move but if a six and eight takes be
black would have to recapture with the
Queen and this would allow deform and
this structure here kills the dark
square Bishop the take say was played
Queen takes a white recaptures and
develops strikes at c6 for a second time
black defends and develops - not the
best square better is Bishop b7 the main
difference between these two posts is
that from b7 the bishop watches over a
six and this is a key square because it
no longer allows white to challenge the
black Queen by playing Queen to a6 okay
Bishop d7 and now a move that I need
your help with very mysterious move rook
to a2 don't have an answer to it I can't
quite make out what the point of rook a
to was feel free to make some
suggestions or give me some insight as
to what rook to a2 is doing the only
thing that I could come up with is that
it preparing to challenge the Queen by
way of c2 but as will soon see that's
not really that wouldn't be a good idea
let's just say what black follows up
with is rook a to e8 let me point out
that at this point here rook a to again
I can't make sense of it it is already
on this this moment here moves 16 for
white it is already imperative
that white challenge the black queen on
d3 with Queen a6 rook a to instead rook
88 or better described black got their
last piece involved all the black pieces
are working Queen side pieces don't
really have much of a say in this
position Queen a6 is played at this
point that's one way to challenge the
Queen another Queen c2 sure it
challenges the Queen but this is no good
can you figure out why if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video what would you
play is black in this position alright
black has a million-two Queen takes rook
rook e1 mate queen a6 prevents this
tactical sequence this matin - threat
Queen takes rook can be met with Queen
takes Queen Black has another idea in
mind though I wonder if you can spot
Paul Murphy's 17th move if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video what did Paul
Morphy play next
okay the winning continuation is Queen
takes Bishop investing a lot of material
of course what is accomplished exactly
well White's King side structure is
destroyed isolated pawns and open file
towards the White King week square on h3
black immediately gives the check King
is flushed to the corner
Bishop h3 threatens a matin - how is
white to fend off all of these threats
what stride is rook d1 this allows a
mate and six Queen d3 is suggested by
the computer preparing to meet a bishop
check in Bishop f3 with Queen takes rook
like would have something even in that
case on Queen d3 black and first play f6
and these threats are still present in
the game was rook d1 and as mentioned
this is now a checkmate in six
black does not and the game like that
but gets it to a point where he
understands that he's going to win goes
for black goes for a sequence where
they're sure they could get the White
Queen at this point it is a mate and for
starting with rook g2 the idea is to
capture on f2 with Czech or even rook
takes h2 and then getting into h1 for
mate
there isn't a way to stop all of these
threats for example Queen d3 you can
play rook takes f2 Kim Ji Won and pick
your favorite spot to go at the king it
doesn't matter
in both cases rook g1 and that's game
over note that this is double check
after King to f1 we have the bishop
revisiting g2 king has to go back into
g1 discovered check bishop h3 king h1
and now Bishop f2 let's just pause for a
moment here we have all white pieces are
and all the white pieces around the
Queen side and all the black pieces are
on the Kings side where is the white
defense is just not there and the threat
here is to simply give made on g2 now
that g1 is covered there's no pawn
anymore so there's no pawn anymore on f2
so the bishop controls g1 black saw with
this variation that white has to now
give up the Queen and does with Queen f1
to defend g2 Bishop takes Queen rook
takes the attack continues rookie two
very active pieces and still these Queen
side pieces are doing nothing this pawn
is in a pin white gets out of it with
rook a1 rook h6 targeting h2 after now
d4 a nice finish
touch here is Bishop III preventing
Bishop takes rook and looking to crash
through for me it is at this point that
Paulsen resigns after Bishop III white
resigns Bishop takes Bishop would run to
a million one and then two and there's
no good defense against that because g1
is covered in the computer's eyes look
f2 is best but this is of course losing
for white so very interesting game I
have a couple things that I want to
share as a close one is a question and
that is on this move 17 did you spot
this tactic and the other thing is if
you did not spot this tactic with Queen
takes Bishop how might you have one
thing to keep in mind here is that white
is without two pieces they're not
playing with the Queen side rook they're
not playing with the Queen side Bishop
and there is a significant amount of
pieces that black has in play clearly
along the e-file the bishops are both
pointing towards the king this might be
your cue to look for outlandish type
moves like a Queen sacrifice especially
one that will impair the enemy Kings
structure severely double isolated pawns
isolated pawns we have a lot more
aggressive pieces when we consider
attacking pieces versus defending pieces
where are the defending pieces for white
there's just a rook around but there are
two rooks and two bishops here attacking
the White King these might be some
things to look into these might be some
good visual cues for you to maybe spot
these sort of tactics in a position just
recognizing those imbalances numb
of attackers versus number of defenders
so a very interesting game it's quite
typical with the Paul Morphy games that
he has this initiative something that is
brought about by having a lead time wise
and it often finished in a beautiful
fashion and in this case with a queen
sacrifice so as usual I hope you're able
to take something away from this game
and feel free to leave any feedback in
the comments section below that's all
for now take care bye
you